good morning millennials welcome back to
the toast happy wetness day a gorgeous
day here at the toast because it's hump
day you're halfway through the week how
should we celebrate oh I don't know
maybe by humping someone you love which
I already did today because I woke up
with Theo in my arms hey Jax how you
learn doing good I think we should
celebrate with another episode of the
toast
I love where your head is at it's kind
of a strategy it's a crazy idea but you
have to hear me out I feel like that's
what people need to get through to the
latter half of the week I mean it is
what we usually do and what we usually
do like is working for us so I say stick
to the stuff you know if you want to be
cool follow one simple rule Don't Mess
With the Flow no no
you're 100 right we should stick to the
status
quo octave change no no no no such a
good song and such a good message
is it a good message it's actually not
it's actually such a good point it's
like the worst message no the point of
this song was like they were trying to
get Gabriella to not to stay in her box
yeah to stay in her box and like you
know only hang out with a certain group
of people and don't even think about
blending and we love blending you know
what it's like Martha you can't pop and
lock and jam and break like you must
stay in your lane yeah but she should
have you seen her gym have you seen her
break that's what she's born to do have
you seen her Tick Tock she's literally
dancing around the world and if she had
stuck to the status quo we would never
know dancer Martha we would only know
nerd Martha right so why they have to go
and name her Martha why not
no offense to our Martha toasters it's
just not it's not like the most young
fabulous vibrant name depends on the
Martha
so true I know a great Martha
so do I yeah
you're right anyway like that's the
thing about names like yes the person
becomes the name the name but sometimes
the name becomes a person and they just
they can't you know
Take Back Control
yeah well that's on them they're out of
control right their personal
accountability they're spiraling
personal accounting important get a grip
so stick to the status quo when it's
working and when what you're doing is
really amazing and that's what the title
of the song should have been stick to
the status quo when it's really working
and when it's really amazing I would say
that the students though the Wildcats
would have said like the status quo was
working there was peace and Harmony in
the land always playing Devil's Advocate
but they didn't know how good it could
be right right they were blinded yeah by
the quo
by the quo that was statist can I tell
you something I'm like struggling with
you know new conversation tangent sure
so you know this weekend is opening
night of the eras tour and like I'm
struggling with the fact that I'm not
going to be there like I did think about
maybe getting on a flight to Arizona but
honestly I need a break from travel
um but like so much content is already
coming out on Tick Tock like people are
standing outside State Farm Stadium they
are filming because you can hear she has
to rehearse and so they're filming like
and knowing what songs are on the
setlist like I already know two songs
that are on the setlist like I'm really
annoyed
um and I don't know how to like preserve
my experience because my show my first
show is not going to be until May
um so I I don't know how to like you
know engage with the Swifty Community
when they're kind of being toxic right
now and like giving spoilers where are
you seeing the spoilers Tick Tock all
over Tick Tock and the first show hasn't
even happened once the first show
happens like people are more than
welcome to share I'm not going to judge
them for that but like do I even want to
see that and you can't just like limit
your tic-tock use until this weekend or
are there ways to do filters on Tick
Tock where you can like
make sure that you're not seeing
anything Taylor Swift Swifty I mean I
could limit my Tick Tock usage I just
think it's important to be realistic in
a scenario can you do filters on tick
tock I know you I don't know if you can
block like a hashtag I feel like you
could
but I've also been getting like really
good inspo for like what I should wear
um so it's been helpful but it's also
being toxic I feel like you could figure
out what to wear
yeah I was actually thinking about that
outfit at the top the outfit I wore in
Lisbon with um that's like been a lot of
people's inspo for the eras tour I know
I didn't even think about it but that
dress is so lover era yeah
so I don't know it's just something like
I'm struggling with I feel like a lot of
swifties can probably relate to like one
I want to know and then it's like once
the show actually happens like do I
watch all the videos or do I wait for it
to be a surprise I think when I saw a
reputation like I knew everything that
was gonna happen and it didn't really
make a difference in how much fun I had
you know yeah Chili's makes every show a
little special that's true I just can't
believe it's here like we've been
talking about this for so long you know
yeah
and I still don't have tickets it's time
Stoneham tickets
um
don't even have like a lead but again I
just I'm not worried you know yeah
what's meant for you will find you I
don't chase I attract
so I hope that brings you peace turdy
Lou thanks Jacqui
um why don't you just make like a quick
celebratory announcement congratulate
our girl Jackie oh this morning she
reached 300 000 followers on Instagram
which I don't know if like as a society
like we're Beyond sharing like the
hundred thousand Milestones but I'll
never be over it like it's so exciting
it's so exciting we're Beyond like you
know Balloons with 300 on them and then
cancel that delivery I had turning to
your house like I'm not gonna post
something in feed like 300K because
every time like someone does that then
they dip below yeah no and I do like
always roll my eyes I'm a congrats who
cares but I think we can orally
celebrate you know because we were
talking about it this morning that's
what we do on the show is talk about the
things that we're talking about and
that's kind of like been big news in our
world this morning is that I hit 300K
and then I'm just like growing on
Instagram and it like it just feels
exciting because like when you go to
your page there's a new number like I
remember when I went from 100 to 200 on
Tick Tock like I felt different do you
feel different no
well because uh I like it right right no
I don't feel different but it's just
it's nice and also as I try and grow my
business like it's always good to have
more followers and so it's worse
business is good
business is good you want to know why
because you're sticking to the status
quo no I feel like I'm not sticking to
the satisfy I feel like I've been
switching it up yeah you have pretty
much and I feel like actually I have
been switching up my content a little
bit recently just being like a little
more
real yeah because rails people are real
people and I feel like I'm attracting
new audience you I feel like maybe I
tapped out on what I was doing before
right now you have so much to say so
much to share so many things I'm
learning every day
I'm learning something new every day
especially in my driving excursions
right and by the way another tour
starting up soon is Luke Combs which
we're definitely gonna go to a show or
two yeah it's very exciting to be a fan
of good music these days it is it's also
exciting to be a country music fan when
summer comes because there's always good
tours and animals I actually live near
like a lot of different venues that I
could go to you do and so I'm really
excited to see Luke Combs Morgan Wallen
lady a there's also a big country music
festival down here in a Tortuga Tortuga
and so I need to look at the lineup and
see if that's worth pursuing and I just
started planning my Stagecoach you know
last year I decided last minute not to
go and I gave all my tickets to Margo
which was so nice to me
um I did make her pay for them that was
misleading
um and I had a lot of regrets but I had
MSG the next week and I just thought
it'd be irresponsible to be like out
partying for four days before like one
of the most important nights of my life
and now I'm going I'm planning to go I'm
very excited I gotta get my outfits
ready it's gonna be great I'm into
Stagecoach in years yeah that's gonna be
really fun I'm sorry I know it's hard
for you to hear not really especially
when let me look at the tortuga lineup
yeah Tortuga is like low-key like a
major country Festival I feel like
people don't talk about it because it's
randomly in Fort Lauderdale but it's
like on the beach and it's really
beautiful and they get like major major
Headliners yeah okay oh my God this was
last year I think literally the best
lineup ever I don't even want to watch
this year this year
Eric Church Shania Twain Kenny Chesney
pretty good yeah if I'm looking for a
night out with country music like it's
pretty good on the beach yeah
good things good things I love Festival
season for me like I don't like you know
Coachella and stuff but country music
festivals if you haven't been like I
highly recommend even if you don't like
country music but you can appreciate it
just survive Talent it's just something
you appreciate good music and live music
excuse me it's true
um if you appreciate like just talent I
think and who doesn't appreciate talent
I think you'd enjoy it it's a great Vibe
yeah
so I'm excited about those things yeah
I'm also excited that it's Wednesday we
have deer toasters we actually have so
many good submissions I was teetering I
almost had four because they were so
good but I'll save the next one oh my
God turdy Lou children keep it in your
pants no there's one that's like real I
know people are not gonna like what I
have to say
um I love that for you yeah throwing you
into the fire I almost didn't included
because I'm like oh let's just give like
another thing for people to hate us
about
um but you know what like I love it I
think it'll I think it'll spark
interesting debate interesting
conversation obsessed what's the topic
please you're just like teasing me now
the topic is
the disabled
yeah no it's kind of crazy
okay I don't know how to like summarize
the topic in another word other than
that should we just like do it right now
because I don't know if I could wait you
know what I said I have four so maybe
I'll do the other three let's just do
this one right now okay right like um
Claudia which is so crazy because we
said we were gonna stick to the status
quo today and we're not but we're not
but as we also said amazing things can
happen when you break free from the
status quo we're breaking free stuff
okay ready
hey Jackson turd I'm a long time
listener thank you both for getting me
through life as a new mom and a nurse oh
now that I didn't realize I kind of
skimmed through the bio she's a nurse so
it makes sense why she's having the
Salama
okay my father-in-law passed away last
December prior to that he was given a
handicap hanger for his car due to his
inability to walk long distances fast
forward to now my mother-in-law still
uses the handicap sign and parks in
handicapped parking all the time it
drives me absolutely nuts she's not a
malicious person or ill intending but I
know that it's wrong how do I confront
the situation should I say something at
all she has absolutely no reason other
than wanting to park closer to entrances
please help I'm just a toaster trying to
do the right thing and make the world a
better and safer place for all people
so what my initial thought was like it
is unequivocally wrong
to use a handicap
placard when you don't need one it's
it's for people who need it but I don't
know like this woman just lost her
husband like maybe this is her way of
grieving those things expire at some
point like she won't get a new one like
I don't know just like leave her alone
and if her husband just passed away
she's probably not extremely young like
right even if she's say 50s 60s like she
wants to park closer to the store let
her
and
um
like you said they do expire So
eventually like her her time will run
out but if this is like one small Silver
Lining to like what she's been through
in the last years like she gets to take
her handicap pass out for a joyride
I I wouldn't be such a narc yeah she's
not like a 16 year old Sprite lady right
like using her grandfather's that's
really [__] up that's messed up yeah
I I just feel like this is a situation
where I would just like mind my own
business yeah it was just like uh
pretend like I didn't notice that what
are you gonna do about it say something
to her like don't be a narc come on
she's going why not and this woman just
like lost her husband like give her the
last few months of the parking pass
it'll be up soon yeah and then she'll
have to deal with what she's probably
avoiding yeah long walks to the
supermarket yeah no I mean we've all
been tempted you know to just pull into
that spot driving around the parking lot
for hours and hours
um and it's wrong it's wrong but I don't
know you know she's a little old lady
she's alone now she doesn't have help to
carry the groceries to the car I can
think of so many worst people who could
abuse that placard you know what a
little old lady with her groceries like
sure you could park at the front yeah
and I will say I don't know because I
have obviously don't have a handicap
placard but I feel like most of the time
I don't know if there's like many many
situations where like a a handicapped
person cannot use the spot because
someone else is using it like whenever I
see them they're always empty like
people really do respect the handicaps
parking spots which they should
um so I don't know I just feel like you
know
it's okay let it go yeah but I know I'm
gonna be called ableist for that so
that's why I was just like talking about
hot take got it
oh Maybe
the word able is really fast and loose
these days I feel like we had this
conversation a few weeks ago like
everything can't be ableist you know
yeah
like people on Tick Tock make these
crazy arguments like such stretches like
you like you like literally the most
mundane thing like that's ableist and
it's actually rooted in misogyny no but
then like [__] that's actually ableist
like literally atrociously vile
statements
yeah so I'm not ableist I just think
it's important to say that but that was
like your little your little teaser a
little palette cleanser yeah for deer
toasters which is at the end of today's
episode I just like to like prioritize
things that need to be fixed in the
world and like the little old lady using
the handicap placard after her husband
just passed away and it's like this one
small win for her it's not it for me
it's our me for you and for you and this
is also a great time to remind you guys
if you're dealing with something email
us dear toasters gmail.com we will
always keep your prompts Anonymous and
if you're dealing with something whether
it's mother-in-law's handicap placards
whatever it is shoot us an email to your
toasters at gmail.com
okay and I think with that little with
Caesar we can get into the stories yeah
so without further Ado here are the
fastest stories that you need to know
and today's episode is brought to you by
ZipRecruiter you know as little girls
Jackie and I always stood out whether it
was you know Jackie's vibrant hair my
gorgeous singing voice but it's tough to
stand out especially if you're a
business owner and you want to attract
the most talented people to hire on your
team ZipRecruiter makes it easy right
now you can try zip recruiter for free
when you go to ziprecruiter.com toast
zip recruiter helps you stand out to the
right candidates their technology sends
great candidates to your job and you
could send a personal invite to your top
choices ZipRecruiter also makes it easy
for candidates to apply to your job
instead of filling out a lengthy
application they can apply with just one
click to to help your job catch the eye
of great candidates ZipRecruiter also
offers attention grabbing labels like
remote training provided urgent and more
get your job noticed by the best and the
brightest candidates with ZipRecruiter 4
out of five employers who post on
ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day Jackson I can
attest to that we actually use zip
recruiter many times over the years to
hire for different positions when it
comes to building out you know the toast
team at toast HQ see for yourself go to
our exclusive link to get a to try zip
recruiter for free and that's
ziprecruiter.com toast again that's Zip
Zip recruiter.com toast ziprecruiter.com
t-o-a-s-t ZipRecruiter the smartest way
to hire
again whether you have a side hustle
you're looking to grow your business
you're running a company whatever it is
zip recruiter is really the best place
to find quality candidates they make it
so easy I find a lot of the time like
whether you're applying for jobs or
looking for people to hire it's so
unnecessarily complicated and
ZipRecruiter is uncomplicating things
today's episode is also brought to you
by Perfect bar looking for a protein bar
that actually tastes good well look no
further than perfect bar with their
lineup of fresh from the fridge protein
bars perfect bar is exactly what you've
been looking for no chalky artificial
aftertaste here
made with freshly ground nut butter
organic honey and 20 organic superfoods
perfect bar has a variety of products
like protein bars little snack size bars
that are also good and good for you they
have tons of different flavors whatever
your palette is I'm always reaching for
the peanut butter with the dark
chocolate and a little bit of a flaky
sea salt so good I love that they keep
in the fridge because then the chocolate
gets like nice and hard and it's just
like delicious
um
they're packed the snack size bars which
are great to just throw in your purse
are packed with up to six grams of
proteins and 150 calories a little goes
a long way and you will stay full
they're made with whole food ingredients
they contain no artificial preservatives
that's why they're stored in the fridge
which I think makes a lot of sense you
can grab one after a workout for a quick
bite while you're out shopping you can
feel good about what you're snacking on
if you aren't convinced already they're
also non-GMO project verified
gluten-free soy free kosher and low GI
so perfect bar knows that it'll be Love
At First Bite for a limited time they're
offering you a chance to try their
refrigerated protein bars for free
here's how it works sign up for email or
texts upload a picture of your receipt
from your local grocery store and they
will reimburse you for the cost of one
bar directly into your venmo or PayPal
account all you have to do is go to
perfect snacks.com toast to get a free
perfect bar today that's perfect
snacks.com toast to get a free perfect
bar today happy snacking happy snacking
I love um helping people get free snacks
that's kind of of like the I feel my
mission on this Earth the reason to tear
reason to tell okay our first story some
fashion drama Zendaya stylist law roach
says he's retiring due to politics and
lies so Zendaya stylus was also styled
many a star but he's most famous for
Zendaya because one she has the best
style and I think they've worked
together for the longest and the most
events he's all he's also known for like
specific moments maybe not clients like
Zendaya but I think he did a lot of
Ariana Grande's music videos during her
iconic music video era yeah he's also
dressed Megan the stallion Hunter
Schaefer Carrie Washington Celine Dion
Ari Priyanka Chopra Lindsay Lohan
Addison more
um but today also because she's just
like the most fashionable girl on the
planet and here's the man behind it
anyways he posted a picture saying
retired with the caption my cup is um
empty thank you to everyone who have
supported me in my career over the years
every person that trusted me with their
image I'm so grateful for you all if
this business was just about the close I
would do it for the rest of my life but
unfortunately it's not the politics the
LIE and false narratives finally got me
you win I'm out
this was shocking for a multitude of
reasons one he's not particularly old
and he's not particularly like uh washed
up like he's at the top no he literally
like just was doing stars of the Vanity
Fair Oscars party this weekend and so
many of his clients and just like major
major celebrities were commenting on his
post like what no you can't so it seemed
like it was something nobody knew about
um and obviously the internet has
flocked to find the reason and and they
think they found it there there is this
video going around from very recent I
think last week Paris fashion week he
went to the Louis Vuitton show with
Zendaya they both walk out to the front
row the person shows Zendaya her seat
and law doesn't have a seat and Zendaya
points behind her there's a seat
directly behind her in the second row
she's like oh that's gonna see it and he
looks
flustered offended pissed
so I don't know if that's the whole
reason because he said the politics that
could be the seat the seed is Politics
the lies and false narratives
but maybe he got that seat because of
lies and false narratives that are like
circling I felt two ways about seatgate
because on the one hand like who was the
front row four if not the biggest
stylists and the biggest stars and the
people who can actually have access put
their clients in these clothes like I
feel like so often it's like influencers
or just like random people who aren't
buying your clothes who's who's not
followers are it whose followers are and
it's just it's very
and if I was someone who's like a
veteran industry I would see that and be
annoyed like for me as a follower of
people I'm like oh I'm glad my person
was in the front because I got to see
front row view but yeah but when you
think about it it doesn't make sense
that someone who actually has influence
in the fashion world and like can get
these dresses on influential people why
that person wouldn't be in the front row
right like when you think about it those
top stylists like are actually the most
the influencers of fashion because
they're influencing the the major
players like Zendaya yeah and Zendaya
then influences the people Everyone the
culture yeah so I understood why of
course like he should be in the front
row and that is a bit of a slap in the
face especially if there were people in
the front row who aren't A-list or is
and
especially because it seemed like he was
told he would be sitting in the front
row because he walked to the front with
Zendaya I don't think he would have just
assumed that unless he knew
yeah but you like in a situation like
that when it's like bleachers like you
do walk across the floor and then like
go up to your stand no I feel like you
walk from the back
no I don't think so yeah
you walk from the back yeah like
depending on how the room is set up I've
been to like two seated shows and you
walk in like from like at the last row
and then you walk up to the front oh
I've experienced the other one unless
they're walking from backstage
which is impossible too yeah no but I
think you walked everyone like walks on
the floor and like even if the like on
the runway sometimes until the show
starts just to like get up to their
seats
no like what when I'm thinking about the
layout I mean I guess it just depends
where the show is every show is
different but you would walk in from
like the door and you would enter
like the first thing you see would be
the last row
um
it depends on whatever I mean it depends
yeah
um but I just it looked like he was told
that he would get a front row seat
that's why he like you know nobody else
some Anna Wintour doesn't need to be
told that she's gonna get a front row
seat true also very true and and I know
that he's not Anna Wintour but like he
is one of the most influential people in
fashion it's not like he needs to be
promised to Front Row seed in order to
go like it should be expected but on the
other hand it's like it's hard for us to
and lay people in general to like
understand why you get like so offended
about a seat you know right like it's
the front row politics it's a side of
respect yeah no like if you're not a lot
has worked if you're not front you're
last a hundred percent and I think it's
like all right maybe when you start out
even if you're having a ton of success
you don't come to expect things like
that but when you're like a veteran of
this industry and you're at the top of
your game and you walk in with Zendaya
like you would expect a little respect
yeah so that definitely would put a pack
of taste in his mouth but not enough to
retire from the industry as a whole so
there's definitely more going on because
if I were him and Louis Vuitton
disrespecting me like that like okay my
clients are just not wearing Louis
Vuitton ever again goodbye is like a
face of Louis Vuitton so that's the
politics it's like you hate Louis
Vuitton because they disrespected you
but a lot of the top clients you work
with are actually faces Louis Vuitton
that have contracts that have to wear
but he could get any new clients that
aren't part of Louis Vuitton yeah but
like Zendaya you don't just give up on
Zendaya
but um this can't be the you know the
one and only reason of course it maybe
it just was like you know the straw that
broke the camel's back but it does
remind me a lot of Michael Costello when
Michael Costello posted because for me
like when I look at Michael Costello
when I look at La rocheck two
unequivocal talents like
so good at what they do
um but both referencing some like Petty
Hollywood [__]
um and it just reminded me a lot of that
like so sad how someone both of these
people who are so talented and have so
much potential kind of being sidelined
what happened in the Michael Costello
situation that reminds you of this like
he posted
um that like he basically was like
blacklisted from and it made sense to us
because we were like he's so talented
his dresses are so beautiful and he
never really got to a level got passed
right he should right and he said
literally I've been blacklisted in this
industry by certain people he mentioned
Chrissy Teigen yeah um but just like how
the it's not even about how talented you
are it's about like the connections the
hot The Swinging you know who you're
with and it should be like a meritocracy
but it's not yeah
yeah I don't know what this is I really
hope that we get more info I also feel
like he's there's no way he's actually
retiring I was gonna say do you think
this is like a
a legitimate retiring yeah I think it's
a little dramatic yeah yeah because he's
he's the top of his game everyone wants
to work with him if you look back in the
last 10 years of like the most iconic
looks in pop culture he's been
responsible for a lot of them so I don't
think you give up something like that
but it's easy to get frustrated when
when again you're not being seen for
your talent it's a cacophony of other
really irrelevant factors yeah and as he
said like he loves fashion if it was
just about the clothes he would do it
forever and so I don't think he's
literally gonna spend the rest of his
life like not doing this thing that he
loves maybe he will pivot into doing it
in a way that he doesn't have to deal
with all this [__] whether that's like
doing his own line or I know he's also a
judge on an HBO Max show yeah all those
things to me sound even more political
but yeah Hollywood
what do I know
um but like you know front row politics
is Extreme the comment section on his
Instagram is worth scrolling through
it's crazy like the stars were shookath
yeah
yeah I saw um some of them Addison
commented Lisa Rinna commented
and it wasn't like oh you've done it oh
yeah Naomi was like no we will not let
you so it wasn't like everyone oh we'll
miss you you did amazing work bye it was
like no what yeah I don't think they're
gonna let him quit I don't think that he
should quit even though he didn't say
quit he said retired but
um whoever offended him
has some explaining to do we are in
trouble you're in trouble yeah do you
think like he's beefing with Zendaya
no because he could just drop her as a
client yeah and he could give all those
looks to someone else right
she really is like the It Girl of
fashion and if like and if he really has
beef with her like he could find whoever
and he probably spends a lot of time
with her he probably knows whoever her
like
whoever she's always competing with I
don't even know who that would be give
them all the looks
use a new stylist and is not a
competitor but like similar Cindy
Sweeney Sydney Sweeney like her looks
are always aging her she's always
looking matronly I know she has a
partnership with Tory Burch and I just
don't think it's like a good match for
her
um so if you wanted to get back even
though like Zendaya is so much bigger
than Sydney Sweeney but they're both on
Euphoria and Sydney Sweeney is going to
have a very long career ahead of her
um he could he could go to her because
she's in dire Dire Straits she's in dire
need yeah it's also interesting like to
me he seems like the number one stylist
in Hollywood but then some of his
clients it's like oh how'd you get to
work with him like yeah maybe he's
really loyal and like people who worked
with him when he wasn't the biggest
he stuck by people who stuck by him yeah
like he didn't like Seinfeld for Vanity
Fair
I actually literally like what she wore
um look I just didn't like the length of
the dress the dress is really really
beautiful but like for me I'm a gown or
a mini girl like that in between I know
it's very high fashion like teacup like
right above the ankle I don't like that
personally but I know I could be wrong
I'm obviously you know I'm wearing the
same pants for the fifth day in a row
what the [__] do I know oh I think I see
it uh no this is 20 20. wow it's like a
silver dress that like really cuts her
off like before her heels I hate that is
it this one
I can't see what you're showing me it
says 20 20. there's no way
whatever it's irrelevant but
um hailee Steinfeld is still like really
major
she's been like quiet for a few years
but she's like a huge Global following
it's like kind of crazy what is she
major doing right now would you no I
just said not right now I'm just saying
in general she's like an oscar-nominated
actress she's a pop star she was like
the lead in you know Pitch Perfect she's
major I would say she's major okay the
dress goes all the way down to the floor
not what I saw it she's wearing a coat
with it
it's fashion for sure I know and that's
that's one thing about me like I will
critique everyone and everything
meanwhile like I'm a slab who knows
nothing I think that's important I'm
crying because her dress is down to the
floor covering her heels next story
Lindsay Lohan is pregnant expecting her
first baby with Vader Shamus
Lindsay is pregnant expecting expecting
her first has first baby with her
husband Vader Shamus her rep says she's
feeling great and she's thrilled she
shared the news via Instagram on Tuesday
with a photo of a baby body suit that
said coming soon on it and then her rep
confirmed that she is pregnant and
they're expecting a baby so welcome to
the pregnancy Bunch this is a great one
for the crew huge for the community I
literally forgot she was like married is
she married yeah I totally forgot I've
been married for a while now like she's
really very low-key settled settled and
you know married pregnant like very
traditional
and by the way the comments were so nice
like Lacey Chabert Gretchen Wieners
Paris Hilton po all the apparent trap
Queens like it was actually really nice
to see all the people who still wish
Lindsay well I feel like everyone who
has worked with her like really roots
for her which is so nice to see but I
also feel like in the last few years I
feel like we still like kind of write
Lindsay off as like
who knows what she's doing she's you
know she's Lindsay she's Lindsay but
she's in like working recently and going
to like doing interviews and red carpets
and she's very
just like for lack of a better word like
normal in the sense that like she's just
working in Hollywood right now and and
being a wife and and a future mom and
like going about her business not doing
what she was doing before which was you
know like running around the globe and
Instagram living yeah and the club in
Mykonos yeah oh right you know like
she's just settled down now and I feel
like she's been doing it for at least a
year or two she was in that Netflix
Christmas movie and like it's really
sticking yeah no I feel like she's in a
good place there was like a rough couple
of years
um but she seems really happy I'm so
glad she's pregnant I think that's so
cute and it's at the same time as Paris
which is just like so crazy you know
like all the girls are growing up all
the girls are growing up I watched a
clip of an interview that she did
recently Lindsay and like I was just
struck by how sober she sounded not in
like an uh actually drunk drunk sort of
way but just in like a lucid yeah like
she's just had so many eras of her
career that you just expect expect her
to be one thing at this point but then
when you actually hear her speak it's
like oh she's just same old Lindsay yeah
I agree it's nice I'm really happy for
her yeah I'm really happy for her and
Dina's becoming a grandma I'm excited
for the pregnancy content yeah and the
look she needs like a she needs like a
big cover you know yeah we need like a
Lindsay explainer in order for this era
to feel really
relevant yeah like she's back and she's
been back so like why isn't anyone
reintroducing her right she needs like a
Vogue cover and like honestly being
pregnant would be so beautiful like she
needs like this like a reintroductory
reintroduction to society or a book or a
documentary yeah but I also feel like
doing a book in a documentary is like
really traumatizing when you have like
so much trauma and I feel like maybe
she's just at a good place and doesn't
want to relive it which I totally
understand too yeah but Tim sort of sit
down like where we're just turning over
a new Leaf yeah I would love to hear her
talk about like all the times she was
interviewed like because now those clips
go so viral like old interviews where
people were so rude and dismissive and
misogynistic about like the place she
was in and like she's really kind of
become kind of like Britney like um an
example of like how the media really
destroyed all these young women's lives
and I would love to hear her talk about
that so maybe she's like hesitant
well she's definitely burned by the
media so I understand why she's not
desperate to like go run and do a cover
or like sit down with Oprah because even
like some of the questions Oprah asked
her have come back and been like
question mark yeah she needs a podcast
100 living Lohan she needs to where she
needs like some very open loving
sisterly hosts trusted sources who
would let her speak her truth and we
don't edit
we don't edit we don't edit unless you
unless you would ask us to of course I
would do anything for Lindsay do you
feel like a kinship to Lindsay like
red-headed Queens well she left the
tribe for many years so yeah but like
when we were younger like you were
literally the quintessential redhead and
so was she and she was like our eyes and
she was a really good redhead role model
for a while yeah like she always like
had good like redhead hair and makeup
and like made really redheads like seem
so beautiful and so yeah I do but then I
feel like I forgot how I felt about her
when I was like younger because now I
just think of her as like when she was
blonde when she was brunette and she was
she was so she was not red for so many
years that I kind of forgot she's a
redhead
what do you think is Lindsay's most
underrated film
hmm
Confessions of a teenager I'm a queen I
know you're going to say
oh no oh my God I forgot I was gonna say
Herbie Fully Loaded
not the most underrated but she's so so
good in everything like if you watch her
be fully loaded it's like a dumb Disney
movie whatever like she's really so good
and she's so committed to that car no
she's so committed to the car she's
really I feel like she's literally like
acting with a car it's like when she did
Parent Trap she was acting with no
herself and then herself like I think
people really forget like she's such a
talented actress like that's why she
blew up when she did she is a star she
has real talent no she really does and
even when she comes back and does movies
like she's a really great actress she
was didn't just like blow up because
she's a celebrity and weird she was cute
care about like the tablets like she's
an amazing actress Mean Girls obviously
Freaky Friday just my professions of
just my love life size oh my God Eve's
great no matter where she goes
she's an amazing actress that's why like
whenever she wants to come back to the
world of acting like she'll be great
it's in her back she's very talented
thank you for bringing up Georgia rule
any excuse to talk about that film and
if you ever want to know why Rotten
Tomatoes is literally a not trusted
source and you should never make any
decisions based on Rotten Tomato all you
need to do is look up the scores for the
lobster and Georgia rule one of them has
like a hundred and one of them has a 30
and one of them sucks and one of them
doesn't and it's not what you think yeah
George really was so good oh such a good
movie Lynette skabo Jane Fonda
story older man
the guy the guy Jackie
yeah who is like everything to everyone
yeah oh and then there's an older man
right for Jane Fonda who's uh Carrie
elwis which you wouldn't recognize the
name but he was just in that
Christmas movie with Brooke Shields that
we watched the Scottish Castle
such a bad movie like next level bad it
was so good it was so good it wasn't
great no it was it was big budget you
know Netflix Christmas movie which is
is good but Brooke Shields should really
be ashamed of herself like that was that
was bad yeah
yeah well actually that's a great segue
into our next story which is getting a
bump up okay because Nancy Myers is 130
million rom-com is no longer moving
forward at Netflix and the project is
looking at new buyers so a lot of
Industry info here Netflix has pulled
the plug on Nancy Myers's next movie a
star-studded romantic comedy that would
have marked the director's first film in
years over budget concerns but don't cry
into your cashmere sweater just yet
turdy Lou sources with knowledge of the
project said the filmmaker is looking
into other options to make the movie
prior to the film reportedly titled
Paris Paramount being shelved Scarlett
Johansson what's the title Paris
Paramount
not great uh yeah Scarlett Johansson
penalty Cruz Owen Wilson and Michael
Fassbender were being courted for lead
roles pending Talent availability the
project will be shocked to prospective
buyers as a package One Source added so
Netflix announced the rom-com in April
2022 and greenlit a price tag well over
100 million dollars a source confirmed
to a variety Nancy wanted 150 million to
produce the film but Netflix wouldn't go
over 130. it's not clear how much of the
budget is set aside for Nancy's paycheck
versus you know like the kitchens yeah
um the kitchens she was set to right
direct and produce this movie which is
semi-autobiographical it's a story about
Hollywood X's who end up working
together she was married to director
Charles Shire with whom she had two
children for nearly 20 years as a couple
they worked on several award-winning
comedies such as Private Benjamin baby
boom and Father of the Bride Baby Boom
is so [__] good yeah so then I guess
they split
and they wound up working together again
she hasn't done a fully Nancy picture
since the intern but she did produce
home again which was written and
directed by her daughter I just learned
oh that's sweet home again wasn't her
best and there was it wasn't hers
technically there were predatory
undertones to the whole thing
um it was weird
it's weird it wasn't good honestly I'm
just I feel like Netflix spends so much
money on so much crap and even if this
movie was not good people would watch it
anyway because it's Nancy Myers and she
has such a cult following and I feel
like this is a huge mistake when I first
saw the headline it made it seem like
the movie was never gonna you know see
the light of day it just it's just not
gonna be at Netflix but somebody's gonna
buy this yeah
someone will buy this people will watch
this she's really never flopped when
it's her stamp on everything and this
would be a situation where it's a
completely Nancy production I don't know
who wouldn't chomp at the bit over this
what do you think is Nancy Myers's best
movie
okay let me pull up her catalog because
I just want to make sure I'm considering
all options and I just want to say one
of the biggest mysteries of this world
is the fact that because I said so is
not a Nancy Myers movie It's So Nancy
Myers it's fancy fires with Diane Keaton
and Mandy Moore I always feel like it's
a Nancy Myers movie and it's like
low-key nut yeah The Parent Trap with
Lindsay Lohan is a Nancy Myers movie
which is oh my God maybe Nancy could
Revitalize Lindsay's acting career 100 I
love the intern I think it's like an
amazing amazing movie with an amazing
message me too but it doesn't give me
quintessential Nancy you know Coastal
grandmother about no I think her best is
the holiday
oh yeah read them all one more time
before I make my selection
the intern it's complicated that one you
love that I love that movie The Holiday
Something's Gotta Give you love that
sorry Something's Gotta Give us my
favorite Father of the Bride part one
part two part three is coming now 2020
came out missed it
um Baby Boom Baby Boom is so good
Private Benjamin
irreconcilable differences she worked on
I love trouble
so what did you select the holiday the
holiday I'm gonna go Something's Gotta
Give but the holiday and it's
complicated or close seconds
yeah yeah I like I want to live in a
Nancy Myers film like everyone just has
money and they don't ever seem to be
worrying about money they all have great
style the perfect linen pants like you
know always she should come out with a
homeware line yeah but like she's so
rich like she doesn't need it you know
she doesn't need it but it could be like
you know community service for her to
like give it to the community
yeah and that people could live in these
homes it would be good for people to
live in such relaxing
um
environments she also recently had her
home photographed for um architectural
digest and people were quaking because
it's like finally inside and it was it
was so Nancy it was so stunning yeah
Peak Nancy yeah
so good
damn well hopefully that movie gets
picked up shortly gets made quickly but
not too quick you know don't compromise
because I'm looking forward to watching
it and the cast options yeah I don't
love Owen Wilson in like a serious role
but it's like it's like the room comes
that's not serious no no no like I'm
sorry let me rephrase I don't love
seeing Owen Wilson as like the heart
throw leading man to me and when he was
in Midnight in Paris which is literally
like a Scorsese nope the other one the
other one
what's his
Claude he's like the one he's still you
know the rain in New York City no Selena
Oh Lordy Allen Woody Allen yeah I I did
not feel like he was right for that like
I don't see him in this like Prince
Charming kind of way like I really see
him as like the internship wedding crush
the clown clown I'm sorry I do so I
don't I don't I actually don't love that
selection I love Penelope Cruz who was
The Other Woman Scarlett Johansson
wonderful literally would take a bullet
for her and then who was the other
Michael Fassbender stunning like older
Silver Fox that's what she's great at
like Silver Fox like she could even in a
weird way she could make anyone
attractive like I do not in the
slightest find Alec Baldwin even
remotely attractive but like in that
film I was like yeah it's complicated it
is complicated yeah go Jake go Jake yeah
I just wanted to say I disagree about
Owen Wilson I think there's something
really affable and like lovable about
him and he's like I think he's a cutie
and he could be my leading man because I
like that he's like
silly affable is a good word I'm more of
a Luke Wilson girl and I feel like
nobody even thinks ever to put about
Luke Wilson
yeah he would be great for this they're
always thinking about Owen and I'm
thinking about Luke but they think about
Luke sometimes like he's in Legally
Blonde is there a better role that's
literally all he's at no Claude you just
don't notice him when he's in Step
because he really becomes the character
you know here let's
let's do his movies
hmm
I'm telling you he doesn't got like a
great
he's underappreciated and I think it's
because of his brother you think that uh
when is the superior Wilson in terms of
Fame
yeah
I think it's not even comparable I
wonder why because Luke is more handsome
so I guess like really looks don't win
no I think
um yeah when you take a look at their
like you know resumes it's not even we
always you know reference Owen Wilson as
Emmett from Legally Blonde but beyond
that like I could not name a single role
and Owen Wilson has like a few key
movies that are Blockbusters
Blockbusters and that's Wedding Crashers
that's the internship that's Midnight in
Paris like he has a lot of like major
whereas like I couldn't name anything
other than Legally Blonde for Owen
Wilson I don't think they're even
remotely comparable no but he is also in
like the Royal ten Mounds Anchorman
Family Stone like a bunch of other stuff
but to me those movies was in the Family
Stone to me those movies don't measure
up no Jellystone Wedding Crashers
no no yeah like the family Stone's like
an indie like Christmas movie like not
everyone's seen it right same with royal
Ten rounds but that's probably like one
of his most famous roles yes and I
haven't seen it but it's like on my list
of things to do before I die
yeah I feel like you would not like it
oh really because it's just like
this is Gwyneth in it Gwyneth is in it
which is a plus yeah but it's it's very
like artsy
um but but comedy but not in a slapstick
sort of way
um okay I I played on seeing it I mean
you should watch it because I'd be so
curious to hear your thoughts it's like
you would want to like it because the
concept is a good one but like I just
don't think you would like the way that
it rolls out because it reminds me of
and I don't know if it is Wes Anderson
oh that's like not my vibe yeah is this
Wes Anderson yeah it is oh all right
well I guess that makes sense why it's
the vibe and why it's not your Vibe
right no I'm not a Wes Anderson girl
like not in the slightest no but the the
like the poster for each movie I'm like
oh I would love this movie the the past
Hotel couldn't make it through five
minutes
I saw one was Anderson movie and it was
one of the worst experiences of my life
I went to the movies in college with my
friend Abe and he's like really like
artsy and like into [__] like that and I
just was non-stop rolling my eyes it was
something about like kids going camping
in the ice kingdom
horrible agreed
agreed like so bad
but people love him no and that's what's
so fabulous about art and culture is
there's something for everyone
the key word used to describe Wes
Anderson's style is formalism
that's literally not a word not a word
and definitely not something
let's go and pique my curiosity no no
that's not even a word so
maybe just you don't need to see Royal
Tenenbaums okay
but you shouldn't because it's good like
anything with Gwyneth like I will like I
agree
it's such a big cast I don't know if you
get enough gweneth yeah I need to see
Shakespeare in Love I've actually never
seen that and that's her oscar-winning
role yeah
look at you Shakespeare I'm so literary
like Dirty Lou Shakespeare
William Turley Lou
speaking of names are you ready for our
next story yeah Nikki and Brie Bella are
leaving WWE and announcing a name change
for their next chapter wait what yeah I
know Nikki and Brie Bella have announced
their retirement from WWE as well as a
major name change the twin sisters
announced a decision Tuesday telling
fans they will now be known by their
birth surnames Nikki and Brie Garcia or
the Garcia twins they said on the Nikki
and Bree show on SiriusXM today we are
officially from here on out the Garcia
twins Bree and Nikki Garcia we're going
to be 40 in November where mothers we're
entrepreneurs we're executive producers
we're starring now we're hosting shows
the twins explain that when their
contract with WWE came to an end the
pair just knew it was time to head into
this next Direction next chapter they
said I just Bree said I just want to
thank Brie Bella the character the name
all of it I have been in the last 16 17
years I'm so excited to close that
chapter on Brie Bella put that book to
the side and open up a new one and see
what Brie Garcia is going to do next it
never occurred to me that that wasn't
their name like even though when I think
about it like yeah everyone has like
stage names on WWE like Bree's husband
is Daniel bryanson but he's Brian
Danielson you know like they switched
his name yeah like I get it
um I just didn't ever expect that Brie
Bella and Nikki Bella wasn't their names
because I've just become so accustomed
to that right and that's also become
their brand like they had to show the
Bella Twisters like right you know
they're the Bella twins yeah and they've
lead into the Bella Twins and so I
understand like you know this
differentiation like I want to be Miley
Cyrus not Hannah Montana anymore but
they've spent so many years like
branding money time effort into like the
Bella brand it's really hard to do a
Rebrand I know and you know what this
reminds me of
do you like know at all what I'm gonna
say let me think uh like somebody who's
like a really established brand just
saying like I want to change my name
somebody who is ophelous it happened
like somewhat recently and we were like
what and then the person like never
really enforced the change but like they
legally changed it yeah yeah Kelly
Clarkson yes but did she change it to
like Kelly Brianne or something like
yeah
[Applause]
right it was like so [__] wrapped up
no but like that's a great example
because I do hope that this is like that
where in a year we're gonna be like
remember when they said they're the
Garcias but we're still they're still
the Bellas like in entertainment when
it's when you're so famous and like your
name is your brand especially with them
because they're not just individuals
they're like this brand this team of
twins The Bella Twins it is so hard to
get people to change I feel like even
when people get married people did not
say Kim Kardashian West for a really
long time and once we got comfortable
she changed it back like yeah it's
really hard to be famous and to have a
name change I feel like someone who's
famous who actually had a really
seamless name change was when Claudia
ashrae went from Claudia to turdy Lou
like it happened in days but that's
because like Claudia was really never
Claudia she was like always turning blue
and people never really felt comfortable
calling her Claudia so they were just
like waiting for when she dropped the
new name I thought you were like
actually gonna say like a good example
because a good example I think of and
it's because I really felt like this was
the way her name was meant to be is
Sheena Shea like that's not that's not
her name when we met her she was Sheena
Marie yeah but now she's always meant to
be Sheena Marie Shea but she's not
Sheena Shea anymore yes she is she is
but she knows isn't that Shay's name
yeah but she was married and hold on now
she's married again
oh she's married again wait you're
totally right what is sheena's last name
no there are actually a lot of influence
yes Sheena Shea is literally on her
Instagram
oh same Lauren Lane Lauren Lane no but
even what is her real push now
right no she's Lauren Lane so many
people that I follow on Instagram like
I find it actually oddly easy to switch
to their married names like even I was
looking at JoJo Fletcher and I just
think of her as like Jojo Rogers just
because I'm always like Jordan Jojo and
then I was thinking what is her maiden
name oh I don't follow her so she's
always JoJo Fletcher to me but yeah yes
when you follow someone and they change
their name like even Dana you're the
redhead she's like always always been
Dana holes like that's Dana Hall's Dana
Hall stay in the halls and the day she
got married literally I think she went
to the bathroom after the ceremony and
changed her Instagram name everything
down to her venmo she made a new Gmail I
thought that was crazy
um and I was like damn she's always
staying on holes and that she's really
Dana webman yeah it's it can be done for
a married name
this is a little different one because
like we have so many years of the Bellas
they're the Bella sisters and it really
like it's an entertainment innate and
you know why they chose it for WWE like
it's yeah and it's like yeah
it's Global it's Global it's twilight
it's Beauty and the Beast it's like it's
everything oh totally random speaking of
Bella I started my book for book club
which I told you about it's one Italian
Summer by Rebecca Searle
the way she is painting Positano I'm
going like that's on my list I'm going
in the summer you should like your
maternity leave like maybe I'll take a
week and go like I have to go to
Positano before I die you do and I feel
like even just looking at pictures it
looks the other way even though like she
does also describe like the way the city
is built it's like a lot of stairs
really yeah um and there's like not a
lot of cars but I'll figure it out I
like I'm holding myself accountable I'm
saying I'm going to Positano yeah the
thing about
Positano though I think is like once
you're there there's so many other great
places around then it turns it turns
into like this big virtual Euro trip and
then that's like a lot to wrap your head
around I know but I feel like I would be
okay just seeing one and like I would do
a day trip to Capri it's like if I could
take a car sure but like trains planes
boat I would love love love love yeah I
think you could do it by boat and in the
book The Girl went in June and she was
like it's so much better because it's
really hot but like it's before tourist
season so I'm just I might be gone for a
week you guys I I have to experience one
Italian summer it's totally fine yeah go
and July or August the weather is really
like at its peak that's why it's tourist
season right
no I'm going yeah send me your Rex you
should go no I'm gonna go like this is
my year of yes and I'm doing it good I
love that for you thank you
um
who are we gonna go are we talking about
who are you gonna go with uh Ben oh just
the two of you yeah who else I don't
know like a swirly trip I will be so God
willing So Pregnant you could model down
those steps you'll be fine I can't go
International so maybe we do have to go
and shoot
maybe we do have to go on June if we go
on Junior Camp no yeah I think it's I
think it's like a romantic place too
like oh so you and Ben that's really
sweet I know you don't want to be like
but it's also like a lit place and a lit
time of year it's like so you don't want
to be with like your
crew of like I know of party girls yeah
I do feel like when you go on a lit trip
like it kind of ruins the experience in
the sense that like you're hungover you
sleep all day like you really don't get
to experience like the place you're in
if you're like partying all night like
yes a couple nights for sure but like I
don't know
that's how you felt about Lisbon yeah in
Lisbon like I really could have done so
much more sightseeing if I wasn't
violently hungover sleeping through the
whole day yeah
so I think I would want to take a sober
trip maybe I'll maybe it'll be my
birthday gift to myself I'm literally
loving this for you and also I feel like
positives didn't Olivia go not to she
went to Lake Como also gorgeous also
gorgeous like I feel that's what happens
it's like there's all these garages
places all of a sudden you're on a Euro
trip and you're on the train I need a
travel agent I can't like I feel like
it's so hard yeah I feel like now you'll
get inundated with travel agents no I
need like luxury travel agent who wants
to help me and like I never answer
emails but like I'm really great to work
with yeah you have to know turdy Lou no
thy turdy know that turdy like we like
big rooms big portions big air
conditioners yeah in the book she's
saying like there's no air conditioning
anywhere and she's like so hot the whole
time and she's like a a young healthy
girl you know darn darn darn and um
something I've just been struggling with
yeah
back to the bells do you like the book I
do you know I I
like have been this is my second Rebecca
stirl book and like I love the way she
writes and she's Jewish and like you
could just tell and this book honestly
if you've lost your mom I wouldn't read
this book it's so triggering like
it just really like highlights like how
important moms are and like how no
matter how old you get like you love
your mom and you're so lost without your
mom and honestly like I found myself
getting emotional about it and I feel
like if you lose have lost your mom like
it will destroy you honestly like I feel
that way so that would be my trigger
warning okay but like Rebecca's searle's
thing is magical realism and it's like
both of the books that I've read the
thing that I hate about the book is the
magical realism
yeah but the book doesn't exist without
it I didn't realize there was a little
bit in this one yeah the first one isn't
so magical no it's not realistic it
could be explained away this one can't
yeah
I'm not into magical realism like I'm I
live life in reality I can do a little
I don't like it I can do it that was
like that book you recommended to me
that I [__] hated
but the girl who like burst into pieces
uh the unfortunate importance of beauty
the unfortunate importance of beauty
amazing book so good but you liked
magical realism with nothing to see here
I did but that was because it was like
funny yeah unfortunate importance was so
funny
so bad I might have to read it again so
is that our fourth or fifth Story fourth
oh are you ready for our fifth I am
because we also got to do your toasters
right right right Tom Schwartz was
spotted filming winter House season
three amid scandal
oh man yeah I thought this was
interesting Tom Schwartz was spotted
filming winter House season three in
Steamboat Springs Colorado
despite being in hot water for allegedly
having prior knowledge of Tom Sandoval's
Affair I don't think he's in hot water
over that I think it's just like this
you made your bed with Tom Sandoval so
you're part of Sandoval but you are you
are who you lit like associate with yeah
and I just don't think that I think he
probably knew about it for the last few
weeks but I don't think he's known for
seven months and The Rock hell thing
with him was a cupboard not at all no me
neither I don't know what his real
options were when he found out other
than to be loyal to his friends right
and he's so mad at him he's not a man
with a backbone he's not the one who's
gonna like blow it up and be like do the
right thing I'm not mad at him for that
I'm not mad at him for anything in
particular I just think he's the worst
yeah agreed and now it's like everything
else that he's done that was like
borderline over the last few years it
all and because of how much he allowed
Tom Sandoval to influence and ruin his
life it's like you're a [__] [__]
and schmuck and you lay with dogs and
you get fleas [__] this is who
you put your whole stock in and look
good look at who he is good yeah
when he got also from our conversation
yesterday about summer house I'm like
now thinking like I feel like winter
house is even more unnecessary like when
summer house was like popping off with
like so much drama so many couples like
yeah give us winter house but now like
summer house is like barely hanging on
like being half decent I really don't
feel like they need winter house yeah
also winter house was born out of covid
when they needed show white rice and
they couldn't film and so it's just like
get these people quarantined in a house
and film something 100 but they made it
a little more interesting because it's
cast members from all different Bravo
shows so like now you have Tom Schwartz
Sandoval was supposed to be on the show
before scandal
why would he be on the show though he's
old and like married well he was because
like this you know they put so much
stuff in time Tom and I get it Toms and
like Bravo you people love Tom Schwartz
is another Kyle like an older Tom
Sandoval Sandoval so sorry excuse me is
another Kyle like a someone who's too
old who's taken doesn't really
contribute to like the young party
Licious Vibe yeah well I remember a year
or two ago they wanted Tom Sandoval and
Tom Schwartz to go on winter house and
it was like Tom Schwartz is married like
and they want to go without their wives
like what's so weird so weird but now
Tom Schwartz is single he's been single
for maybe a year at this point like uh
I'm fine with him going on winter house
and because he has all this drama going
on like it's it's a pretty good call
also Brian Betty from family karma is
going to be on it as well
they were spotted having a meal at
Timber and torch it was Schwartz Brian
and a former winter House cast member
Corey Kiefer and then it was also stated
that Kyle and Danielle were there having
lunch with them too so it's going to be
the old crew but then what I found
interesting is Southern Charm is
currently filming which means Austin and
Craig probably can't go uh-huh is Paige
gonna go without Craig that sounds
miserable it sounds miserable but people
love Paige I think yeah she'll be there
yeah you know she's been very quiet this
season her and Sierra
yep they they happen but like they're
just like doing their girly thing yeah
so I feel like winter house could be
good as like this like amalgamation of
Bravo stars but they've got to be Hodge
they've got to be single
I mean Darby should go
Ashley Darby oh my God I don't like the
Real Housewives are like kind of like
the older generation and these are like
the younger so it was Kyle's 40. Kyle's
40 and Ashley Darby's like young yeah
she should go and she's single and she
already dated Luke yeah I feel like Tom
Schwartz except now he's kind of Tainted
but before that like I feel like he
could have met someone on like him and
that girl um Sammy yeah she's so cute
Sam they could have been cute yeah who
said they wanted to go out with Tom
Schwartz
Taylor Taylor but they're filming
Southern Charm they're filming Southern
Charming did you hear the report that um
the rumor that Austin hooked up with
Taylor Shep's EX
I saw it not looking very credible but
when I think about it I I could see it
I'm kind of here for it there were such
good friends on the show I feel like it
would have happened in a natural way
like Austin was always really there for
her she's such a sweet girl Chef was so
terrible and so she deserves true love
and Austin's always looking for a
relationship and like maybe this is the
one for him I would ship as long as they
went about in a kosher manner which we
know that they did the way I'm like
still holding out hope for Austin and
Chelsea
oh my God Chelsea is like so moved on no
I know but like they were perfect for
each other but what's so crazy is you
think of Austin and like all these girls
and that's my issue with Austin is like
whenever he's with someone he acts like
they're his wife and like Sarah is so
committed no uh Madison Lacroix oh yeah
they were literally like living together
and now it's like
done and dusted same with Chelsea and
now like Sierra and Lindsay or whatever
and that's why I kind of don't want
Taylor to get involved with him but like
eventually he has to settle down you
would think but he like weirdly likes
being settled in a relationship but like
doesn't want to get married I don't get
it right right
right what was the story
Tom Schwartz going on in her house cute
yeah I'm still probably not gonna watch
because I feel like if I'm not watching
Summer well I actually am watching
summer house but like it's just a lot I
agree and if Paige and Craig aren't on
it together no thank you agreed um
because that's really like the only
place we get them together all the time
I know and they're really great together
so not for me but I hope he you know
makes an interesting relationship happen
for himself something something
um well those are the past five you
definitely needed to know all of them
um and we're not done yet because it's
Wednesday where we do our advice segment
called dear toasters you guys write into
us and Jax and I do our best to give our
you know most
toxic advice no so it's not toxic it's
not I mean it's all about perspective
it's tough love it's tough love
um so dear toasters is brought to you by
vegamore we have tried everything to get
silky strong healthy hair when we say
everything we mean everything we used to
sleep with like olive oil in our hair so
if you are tired of those ineffective
hair treatments and you are hungry to
try something that actually works give
vegamore a try like we did vagamore can
transform your hair they're clean and
vegan approach to hair health uses smart
Botanicals that promotes visibly thicker
fuller and longer looking hair with help
from vegamore you can get healthy
beautiful looking hair without the
harmful chemicals all their products are
cruelty free and they never contain
potentially harmful chemicals like
parabens or hormones vagamore has
something for everyone looking to
improve their hair Health the grow
revitalizing shampoo and conditioner kit
works together to create visibly thicker
hair and it improves hair from the root
just massage a shampoo into your scalp
for 60 seconds and then follow up with
the conditioner on the lengths and the
ends it's as simple as that I've been
loving the dry shampoo I know you're you
love the shampoo and condition the
shampoo and conditioner because uh once
I started my clean journey I found out
that the shampoo and conditioner that I
like uh has some things that I should
not be using right now so I switched to
vegamore and they are clean hair care
and I love the shampoo and conditioner
and it's made the change extremely
seamless for me like no one said
anything like lesser about my hair if
anything they're saying it just looks
amazing and they just feel so healthy
using clean products
so vegamore has no risk when you're
trying it because they have a 90-day
money-back guarantee but with 91 of
customers saying that they saw visibly
thicker hair with vegamore in just three
months you won't want to run out give
your hair exactly what it's been craving
with vegamore go to vegamore.com toast
and use code toast to save 20 on your
first order that's
v-e-g-a-m-o-u-r.com slash toast code
toast to save 20 at vegamore.com toast
today's episode is also brought to you
by just Thrive let's face it stress
sucks especially when it seems to run
your life keeping you on edge and
refusing to let you relax or unwind but
here's the good news there is now a way
to beat stress before it beats up on you
just Thrive probiotic and just calm are
here to help you reclaim your health
your happiness and your peace of mind
because just thrives breakthrough
formula for probiotics is clinically
proven to balance your gut which is huge
because as much as 90 of Americans have
an overall overgrowth of bad bacteria in
their gut and studies show that an
unhealthy gut can lead to an increase in
stress hormones not only will just
Thrive probiotic help you stay ahead of
things like gas bloat and constipation
when your gut is balanced and healthy
you'll be able to handle stress like a
boss plus just Thrive probiotic has zero
fillers gluten dairy or histamines and
it can be sprinkled into any food or
drink it is a perfect probiotic for your
whole family plus but just thrive
is now introducing the next level stress
busting mood support just calm there's
big buzz around just calm maybe you've
already heard it mentioned by your
favorite Wellness influencers or
podcasts because this product is
scientifically proven to soothe everyday
stress encourage a steady and balance
mood improve overall alertness and focus
and even help you get better sleep up
your Wellness game and beat the bloat
beat the digestive issues the stress and
more with just Thrive and right now when
you go to just thrivehealth.com use
promo code toast you'll get 20 off a
90-day bottle of just Thrive probiotic
and just calm it's like getting a month
for free while you're there check out
their other research-backed products for
optimal gut and immune Health again
that's promo code toasts for 20 off a
90-day bottle of just Thrive probiotic
and just calm at justthrivehealth.com
all right deer toasters for those who
want to submit for next time it's
deertoesters gmail.com I already gave
you guys like a little bit of a
a sneak peek before but I got I got two
more ready okay
hey Jax Ledger Bryson streis first off
those boys terribly love the pot you
guys are doing the Lord's work I'm in
need of a little help in December my
husband and I moved 2000 miles across
the country to a new city where we
literally knew nobody it was the best
decision of my life however my husband
still has no friends it's been really
forward I've been really fortunate to
meet a few other women through various
Facebook groups and stuff but he is
nobody I'm starting to get exhausted
being the only one he knows in the area
every time I bring it up he says it's
different for guys and that he's just
going to join an intramural sports team
in March but he def seems timid he
hasn't made much of an effort to meet
anyone and I'm growing concerned should
I be worried how do I tell him he needs
friends besides me without making him
feel like a loser for the record he has
always been a quiet guy but I'm still
just kind of over being the only person
he has a relationship with outside of
work please send my husband a friend
love a toaster who wants an evening to
herself without her husband
I feel that I feel like sometimes you
know the man is more social sometimes
both are very social but a lot of times
like it's the women who are making
friends and I just wonder if like those
friends that you've made through
Facebook groups like do they have
husbands couples dinner double dates
like that's a really easy way to get him
out there but it also just sounds like
having a social life like isn't very
important to him but I do think having a
social life is important to having like
a balanced life and even if it's just
like one friend that he makes like one
person that he finds that he connects
with like that would be enough for him
dainu so I think unfortunately like most
things for us women like you're gonna
have to do everything the mantle and
literally make us friends for your
husband right and she wants to be
proactive so honestly what Jackie said
is a perfect call like odds are a lot of
the women that you've met have partners
and go out to dinner like just hopefully
you know one of them plays golf like
yeah find a common ground yeah where one
of them like does video games or
whatever your husband likes to do right
all it takes is one in tremend Sports
League actually sounds really good yeah
since he is timid like sorry to give you
more work but maybe you could go with
him
um
putting himself out there and not just
saying he's going to do something so
unfortunately it's more work for you
yeah no of course but she did write in
like asking for things she could do so I
think she's open to like having to put
this another problem on her back but I
also think it's a situation where it's
like you do the work now and the payoff
means nights out for you going forward
like yeah he has a friend and it could
be years worth of payoff for a couple
months worth of finding friends for your
husband but you know what that's just
life like you get out what you put in
yeah and this sounds like a worthy cause
especially since like you love where you
live he does and you love your husband
you want him to to have a life outside
of you he needs a friend to complain
about you two right no that's so healthy
it's healthy so yeah Jackie's Right
double date perfect Perfection perfect
place to start and then stay on top of
him about like joining that intramural
league and like oh I'll come with you
hey babe like stay on top of that but
you also can do can do a lot with the
double dates yeah that's like easy
low-hanging fruit and fun for you
because you get to be with your Galley
right everybody wins all right final one
dear Jackson Claude Jax congrats on baby
number two Claudia Portugal looks like
the trip of a lifetime I write to you A
desperate woman my husband has recently
become obsessed with baths long long
baths for background we have two kids
five years and four months old we both
work full time his job requires old yeah
his job requires him to be outside in
the cold in the Utah winter I work from
home needless to say we're both very
busy people lately my husband has been
taking these long baths at the most
inopportune times while I'm trying to
cook dinner put the kids to bed etc and
to top it off he always leaves a
bathroom a mess and we only have one tub
he occupies it when the kids need their
bath now we all need a little me time
but it feels like he's trying to skip
out on chores and kid duty how do I
address this without sounding like a
nagging controlling wife
that is tough because that's like kind
of that's that's like actually my
mission in life like how to communicate
things without coming off as like a
[__] wife but sometimes like you just
have to and this is so clearly like him
avoiding responsibility unacceptable
honestly cut the water supply in the
house off like that's disgusting no this
is so unacceptable I'm sorry there's no
me time until the kids are all asleep
yeah like the idea that he's luxuriating
in the bath while you're cooking and
trying to get the kid sound like no no
and you know what like it's it's The
Stereotype for a reason be a nagging
[__] wife like someone else and you
know what's true if he doesn't listen to
you call his mother like this cannot go
on Jackie that's so true it's a
stereotype for a reason like we're
always having yeah they've made it be
true right like if you maybe if you
actually like had a life that you cared
about you would know what it's like yeah
like we but that's so true it's a
stereotype for a reason like you just
blew my mind we don't do it because like
I'm on that I don't nag you I don't know
like right I'm not a Naggy [__] and
no I wouldn't say like Maggie is part of
my personality in fact I'm quite the
opposite I will actually do as much as I
physically can by myself in order to not
ask for help but like still I'm a
nagging [__] wife
oh my God and guess what right it's you
know what it's born out of necessity
guess what turdy Lou I'm proud
you know what same yeah
I'm a proud but Shaggy wife yeah and to
the point when like I say do something
you're gonna [__] do it oh my God I'm
proud yeah proud I think we need to turn
this on its head it's like don't be
ashamed to nag we need to take our power
back yeah oh the house looks great and
the kids are alive and well it's because
I'm a [__] snaggy wife
so right
oh oh you like this this comforter yeah
I'm a big snaggy wife yeah
oh oh the kids made it to school today
yeah it's because I'm a [__] Naggy wife
and that's the only way things are going
to get done around here but I'm such a
[__] snaggy wife and like I don't even
have kids I'm gonna get so much worse
it's crazy like
and you'd think like the in the increase
in [__] nagginess would result in
increase in Ben's productivity and
therefore like the nagging would go down
no but you have as you're dealing with a
special situation with Ben should we
talk about the beans we should because
people need to know what you are up
against and why your Naggy level is so
high because his incompetence level is
what you guys have never seen before in
your lives you guys
I had the experience of a Lifetime on
Wednesday I can't even put into words
every time Ben does something that kind
of gross or just like lazy I'm always
blown away and here are some examples of
things that that are just like yes
standard Ben uses a knife because he
cooks a lot and which is really nice
thank you for cooking and puts the knife
back in the wooden knife container with
food on it so now there's like food that
lives in the knife container all the
time uses half an avocado because that's
what the recipe calls for leaves the
other half of an avocado on the counter
always when he's staying at my house and
and Zach and I have gone on vacation and
they're locking up the house after me I
came home and there was an avocado
avocado on my counter uh toenail toenail
is Extreme yeah so everything these are
like regular creams
so I'm making dinner the other night and
I go into my cabinet where I keep my
canned goods you know beans and such for
chili
and I see this can of chili that's the
can of beans sorry can of beans excuse
me that's not fully sealed it's not open
all the way but like that you know the
the soda can flicker thing has been like
lifted a little and there's an opening
in the kit I'm like is this open can of
beans been sitting out now my next
mistake wasn't just like not throwing it
out but I had to see what was inside and
I was thinking of the last time Ben made
chili which I was talking about in the
podcast we're so proud I was so proud
right before Ben went to LA so what was
that a month ago uh two weeks two three
weeks three weeks
three weeks this open camera three weeks
ago you were romanticizing your life and
here's the price you have to pay three
weeks ago
Ben opened a can of beans partially and
left it in the cabinet I should have
just tossed it like I knew it was going
to be gross but I did open it only
because like if I had to experience it
so did Ben when I tell you I opened up
the can and I physically leapt backwards
I'd never seen mold like that in my
[__] life it was green it was yellow
it was brown it was blue it was all the
colors of a rainbow
it I didn't even I didn't even know how
to dispose of it but I did take some
very high quality photos you know maybe
I'll post them on my Instagram if you
guys are interested
just because like if I needed Ben to see
it I needed then I was like how do I
dispose of this I can't just toss it in
the trash like that's disgusting it'll
like spill out I put it in a Ziploc bag
and then put the Ziploc bag in the trash
and took the trash out it was so next
level inhumane
that's what I'm living with and that's
hi I'm Claudia and I'm a [__] Naggy
wife because it's like not only do you
need to nag your husband Ben clean up
the kitchen Ben do the dishes Ben put
the beans away that's the level of
minutia you need to get to or else
things like this happen
right like I have to be so controlling
in order just to stop a mold infestation
in my home I told you you should press
charges against him for emotional
distress he deserves to be arrested
and to pay for his crimes like I'm not
even kidding like how do we make this
man pay for what he did I don't know and
like oh and by the way he came home and
I didn't even I didn't send the pictures
I wanted to see him in person so when he
came home he came home late he had a
long day he made himself a sandwich he
comes and sits on next to the bed I'm
like oh I want to show you something
and I I'm like do you know you left a
can of beans open in the cabinet for a
few weeks he's like I did oh my God I'm
so sorry I'm like yeah and I had to
dispose of it and I saw what was inside
and I showed him the pictures and he
gets up he's like ew don't show me that
I'm eating I'm like you're eating I have
to see any [__] person [__] you're
being sensitive you don't show me can
you believe like literally burns down
the house I don't want to see it oh my
God it's so sensitive what's so crazy
about this crime is he knew he was
leading town the next day because I
could see how in the world Ben is like I
use beans all the time I'll use them for
my lunch tomorrow you should still put
them in the fridge but maybe you could
say he really thought he was about to
use them again but he knew he was going
out of town and he left them there like
that in the pantry so and when we go out
of town I do I have like a whole routine
like take the trash out and literally we
were leaving for Lisbon and like I did
my whole routine I clocked I close all
the drains like I do a million things I
took the trash out as I'm leaving I find
like a a wrapper something plastic I go
to put it in the trash in the kitchen
there's an avocado sitting in there
in the kitchen like in the kitchen in
the kitchen trash I'm like I just took
this out so there was no smelly food
that would come back a big smelly
garbage I'm like why is there an avocado
in here and he thinks I'm so crazy I'm
like I'm not crazy I know because it's
like my [__] snaggy wife yelled at me
for throwing away an avocado that's how
he tells it to his friends yep yep but
it's like after what you just heard
I side with Charity Lou I stand with
turdy Lou as we all should at all times
this is egregious
so anyways they made us this way yep
we are byproducts of our environment and
I will stop being a [__] nag when
things get done without me asking I will
stop being a [__] nag when there are
things that don't need to be nagged on
yeah
it's so simple so simple
those were deer toasters again that
steer toaster gmail.com
I feel better I actually do
um that's our show there's another one
tomorrow and the day after that
so we'll see you then thank you so much
for listening to the toast the
millennial Morning Show where we deliver
pasta stories that you need to know
everybody Friday on YouTube so uh if
you're watching this on YouTube please
don't forget to subscribe
please don't forget to subscribe and
give this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcast
can be found so on Spotify
and we'll see you tomorrow
bye love you bye